[Música]
actualizamos la información de la
economía con Daniela Blandón Daniela
bienvenida nuevamente Hola Ángela muy
buenos días usted nos tiene más noticias
y muy importante sobre el caos que se ha
generado por cuenta de la aerolínea de
bajo costo en Colombia viva aérea de la
suspensión de sus actividades y todo lo
que esto implicado para miles de
pasajeros que nos tiene pues Ángela mire
miles de pasajeros siguen estancados en
aeropuertos no solamente de Colombia
también de Perú y de Brasil hay
aerolíneas que ya están ayudando a
evacuarlos en sus propias rutas mientras
la empresa culpa a las autoridades
aeronáuticas de su situación estamos
conectando en este momento con el
ministro de transporte Guillermo Reyes
ministro los saludo muy buenos días y
cuéntenos primero Cuál es la situación
hoy Cuántas personas hay varadas en los
aeropuertos qué solución están
recibiendo
Bueno lo primero como a esa introducción
decir que lo normal cuando una empresa
entra en crisis o ha manejado mal
sus procesos de
la pretendida integración en este caso
es culpar al Estado la situación de vida
es un tema que no obedece al Estado el
proceso de integración que se ha
adelantado y se adelanta generaron en la
aeronáutica civil es un proceso complejo
lo sabían inicialmente las pruebas
fueron muy débiles y ahora el proceso
Está siguiendo su curso lo que no pudo
haber ocurrido era que si se preveía una
fecha en que se iban a suspender
operaciones no se hubiera informado
oportunamente para no lesionar como se
ha hecho a tantos pasajeros que dentro
fuera del territorio colombiano están
afectados en estos momentos por el
precio de operaciones ministro
que hacer las personas que están
afectadas entonces aquellos que tenían
un tiquete comprado o los que están en
el aeropuerto varados primero hablemos
de ellos qué pueden hacer
Hoy podemos hablar de más o menos un
millón de personas que tienen tiquetes
de viva no solo para hoy y mañana sino
para los próximos semanas y meses esos
pasajeros estamos tomando medidas a la
espera de Qué decisión se toma hoy
frente a la integración de Avianca y
viva tenemos una reunión con el
presidente de la república para
definirlo hoy tenemos aeropuertos
complicados y muy congestionados como en
Cartagena San Andrés Barranquilla en
Bogotá por supuesto y en Medellín hemos
tratado con otras aerolíneas que han
aparecido disponibilidad de cupos y de
vuelos como habían calatán satena la
posibilidad de que ellos puedan permitir
usar esas sillas y Estamos buscando con
estas aerolíneas colocar vuelos chartes
para traer esos pasajeros bueno toda
esta situación comenzó porque ellos
están buscando una integración con
Avianca pero también la autoridad
aeronáutica ha alertado sobre
los posibles problemas de competencia
que pueda haber de posición dominante
que puede haber de Avianca si se aprueba
esta fusión y hay empresas que también
se están oponiendo a esto Cómo está la
situación hoy cuando se va a tomar esa
decisión de si se pueden fusionar o no y
esto querría decir que viva él ya queda
pues ya que ha expuesta una eventual
liquidación
en este momento está en una Celsius
operaciones una suspensión provisional
están a la espera del resultado de la
decisión Del alto gobierno hoy a ver qué
va a ocurrir frente al tema de empleados
pasajeros y la operación como la
existencia misma de viva
ministro y también le pregunto
finalmente Quién va a asumir estos
costos de de la operación que por
ejemplo Avianca dejó de vender tiquetes
Quién va a asumir finalmente ese costo
van a ser los usuarios por ejemplo no
quien ASUME Los costos en este caso es
vida porque esa es su responsabilidad
ellos vendieron los pasajes
y tiene la aerolínea para compensar o
cubrir esos costos adicionales ministro
Muchas gracias por acompañarnos 24
feliz día